Give Me.
The Stone.
Wow you are seriously loyal piece of Outerwear.
aren't you. Ah yeah, speaking of loyalty.
Hey, we haven't officially met. Cool
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
this is going to
be my Avengers infinity saga deleted
scene for Iron Man and Doctor Strange
swapping places in Doctor Strange
becoming the iron mage so to speak when
he's wearing the Iron Man armor if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Iron Man Doctor
Strange moment from infinity war or
endgame on the video there are a bunch
of other deleted scenes that the writers
in the Russos also revealed in the last
couple of days that we didn't know about
before so we'll just go down the list
here starting with number 5 if you
didn't see it there's a big reward
infinity war and avengers end game most
of you probably know Markus and McFeely
from all the Captain America movies they
also wrote Thor the dark world which
will be relevant in a second but they
also wrote both infinity war and endgame
so a long time ago Kevin Smith said that
they had shown him footage of Doctor
Strange literally wearing Ironman armor
on the set of infinity war on tanis's Q
ship here on route to Titan while they
were in the middle of this big save
trying to defeat evany maw but this was
a couple years ago and nobody saw the
actual footage we didn't know if it
existed or not or Kevin Smith was just
telling a crazy story it sounded like he
was being very truthful based on the way
the writers talked about it know this is
a crazy scene we totally shot it then
for Marvel released an Avengers infinity
war behind the scenes promo that
actually had some behind the scenes
footage from this scene with iron man
wearing doctor Strange's cape so the way
the deleted scene actually went down is
that you have Iron Man going to save
spider-man who got stuck to the ship
because he was trying to save the wizard
as iron Man had told him to do he has
Friday send up the iron spider armor so
you have the iron spider scene but then
you have Ebony Maw torturing Doctor
Strange
in the scene that they had of this was
actually way more hardcore with the
needles getting ready to pierce his skin
so as they drop down to try and figure
out what's going next you have the cloak
of levitation which is intelligent
waiting here next to spider-man they
have that funny moment hey I don't
we met instead of the theatrical cut
what wound up happening is is the Iron
Man sent all of his nanobots to cover
Doctor Strange to save him from the
needles forming the Iron Man armor
around him and this is what he looked
like in the armor notice the cool
variations on the armor and the extra
details of the layer in there so instead
of forming around an arc reactor like
Iron Man's arc reactors they form around
his eye of agamotto in the time stone
the reason why benedict cumberbatch is
wearing the physical Ironman armor and
it's not just all CG is because if you
haven't seen anything behind the scenes
for Avengers infinity war Avengers and
game sometimes this is what they do when
they're filming Ironman scenes with him
in the armor it's not always 100% CG but
that was only half of the scene what
happened is is that after he sends his
nanobots obviously he doesn't have them
anymore so he's left defenseless but the
cloak of levitation does him a solid
covers him lowers him down to the
bulkhead then they have that funny
back-and-forth quipping with ebony maw
about not seeing as many movies as the
kid and they do the aliens joke where he
gets sucked out the hatch like the alien
queen your powers are inconsequential
compared to mine
so three a lot of you will remember that
this isn't the only time the iron man
has ever become doctor strange in the
comics or doctor strange has become Iron
Man they do swaps like that all the time
the what if comics are actually really
good example maybe they'll try that
during one of the animated what-if
episodes even a couple years ago during
the Marvel legacies storyline they did a
version of Iron Man from a future
timeline who'd become so enlightened
that he'd taken the mantle of sorcerer
supreme from Steven strange they never
really explained what happened to Doctor
Strange during that timeline but it's
just another version of Iron Man that
eventually becomes Doctor Strange which
because this is a deleted scene did wind
up making it to screen it didn't even
make it to the DBZ maybe they'll bring
back during a future Avengers multiverse
story we have Doctor Strange 2
multiverse of madness coming up Kevin
Feige already told us literally we'd be
seeing alternate versions of heroes that
we knew from the MCU so even though I
don't think that Robert Downey jr. is
going to come back for that they could
always include some background footage
with him CG as a version of Doctor
Strange so that is not him on screen
actually or they could show us the iron
mage version of Doctor Strange during
that into you remember this isn't the
only time the Iron Man has given his
armor to other people primarily Pepper
Potts like the notable scene from Iron
Man 3 where the Mandarin tries to blow
up his Malibu house so he covers her in
the armor then she saves him but there
was also a really cool deleted scene
that I talked about in an earlier video
where iron man shows that he had nano
armor as early as Iron Man 2 in this
deleted scene and it's not our
collection it's my collection
no offense no you know what I think I'm
actually excited to say our collection
considering oh my god with whose money
my money I'm sorry doesn't mean anything
you know it means something nano ball I
don't want to play with your ball.
They're mostly playing it for a comedy
there I don't want to play with your
balls Tony but it's just an example of
him having this hyper advanced Iron Man
armor technology that he then put to use
during infinity war I think the main
reason why they didn't want to introduce
armor that advanced that
early in iron man's timeline it is
because they wanted to give him a place
to go eventually like they were getting
ready to do the extremest storyline
during Iron Man 3 and if they did the
nano armor in Iron Man 2 it would kind
of giveaway that big twist there's also
some really cool concept art that looks
a lot like the superior Iron Man which
is basically almost a version of the
symbiote armor but it carries with it
the same type of cost the same type of
twist it makes them the worst versions
of themselves so it was a relatively
brief twist in the comics in the number
one the Russo's were just doing their
Avengers in-game commentary I'll
probably do a longer video for it at
some point but one of the cool iron man
deleted scenes that they talked about
that we're probably never going to get to
see is that originally they had a bunch
of different ideas for what the teams
would be when they go back into the past
through the quantum realm and originally
it was supposed to be Iron Man teaming
up with Thor to go back to 2014 and the
events of Thor the dark world on Asgard
they were going to have iron man fighting
Heimdall in an invisible stealth Iron
Man suit that we hadn't seen yet another
new Iron Man armor that he just hadn't
revealed it would have been a big
callback to this scene for Thor the dark
world where the Dark Elves are trying to
use their cloaking device to fly their
ships past Heimdall who uses his power
to sense them even though he can't see
them
So picture them playing that for comedy
with Ironman turning invisible in his
armor and then trying to tiptoe past
Heimdall unsuccessfully till they battle
it out and try to take him down in some
hilarious way most of Thor's storyline
especially the stuff in Asgard with
rocket racoon was played for a comedy
with exception of the scene that he had
with his mother that was the big reason
why they went back to the events of Thor
the dark world because they
retroactively Lee wanted to fix some of
the things about that movie make them
better and also poke fun at themselves
like a lot of you might enjoy Thor the
dark world it is a fun movie but it's
usually pointed to as an example of one
of the weaker MCU movies but hopefully
that explains what was going on with the
Iron Man becoming Doctor Strange seen in
Doctor Strange becoming Iron Man or the
iron mage as he was called when he was
wearing the Iron Man armor let me know
in the comments though now that Doctor
Strange 2 has been delayed do you want
them to try and include a scene where we
actually see iron mage Doctor Strange
from an alternate reality and even
though Robert Downey jr. implied that
he's not going to come back to the MCU
for a long time it would be really cool
if they found some workaround to include
a scene with a version of Iron Man that
became Doctor Strange in an alternate
reality there's a lot of ways to
accomplish that without actually having
to have Robert Downey jr. fly out to
Atlanta to film a scene for that we also
have that what-if animated series that
will hopefully be able to premiere next
summer originally before all the virus
delays what if was supposed to premiere
next year but that might get pushed by a
couple months there was a bunch of other
really cool stuff that they revealed
during these big re watches of infinity
war and avengers endgame and all the
other MCU films I'm also doing my
infinity saga re-watch video Thor is the
next movie that I'm doing that video for
that should post pretty soon later this
week as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see that video
when I post it every one click here for
my brand-new Doctor Strange 2 Ghost
Rider and daredevil video and click here
for my brand new Spider Man into the
spider verse 2 teaser trailer thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!